fun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des troupes
maria 26 ans francky 24 ans domicile
commun le métro depuis quatre ans lui et
chefs de bande
de jours il a voulu faire le chef
limogne il est venu voir
mali si vous jouez trop loin je n'allais
pas j parce que quand on n'est pas le
chef il faut connaître la zone minière
pas en tant qu'il est déraisonnable
expliquer tout ce qu'il fallait faire il
n'a pas voulu m'écouter et s'est pris
sept coups de couteau la règle veut pas
venir dans le territoire où on n'est pas
amis déjà une
et
la loire
il faut qu'on puisse être tranquille
quand on fait la manche
chaque somme c'est comme un ticket de
métro
une zone de zone3 zone 4 jaunes sans
elle ça marche comme ça pour la jungle
s'il dépasse la zone c'est fini
[Musique]
bon
mais
pour toi c'est important d'avoir un
boulot comme parce que c'est long
comment tu ferais comme nous si on est
dans la rue voir si j'ai pas de travail
la première chose c'est pour avoir
l'argent que je donne à la france n'est
pas une solution c'est pas une solution
pour ce faire la manche touax est une
solution en avant ce que vous voulez
c'est déjà la manche déjà pour ça
rapporte pas beaucoup ou leur faut
vraiment y matin jusqu'au soir et comme
je suis marié j'ai une bosse pour les
noyaux prévoyez
de famille normale ce matin à notre avis
la journée montreuil n 8 car qu'est le
week-end que c'est tout vous rencontrez
souvent des frankie ou démaria comme ça
la nuit dans le métro souvent surtout
soit 9 marie chez blizzard mal c'est des
points peuvent vraiment très content et
quels sont vos rapports avec eux ou bien
ils
ont merde quand on travaille
tranquillement attentif on laisse
tranquille ne laisse point qu'ils ont
forcément si on commence à parler avec
eux ont commencé à les envoyer chez là
c'est sûr que ça finit mal
autrement ça se pousse valent bien
moi su respecter parce qu'il m'appelait
papa j'ai pris des coups quand même un
contrôle
j'ai pressé comme bara minutes pourquoi
un pour rien
j'étais assis j'ai un copain ou qui se
fait complètement en deux et comme je
connaissais est ce moi j'ai mon frère sa
place dans métro
je suis depuis 84
1984 qu'est ce qui vous a amené un jour
à décider de pub dans le métro les
problèmes avec ma femme quel genre de
quand même
c'est difficile à dire
enfin il nous rend visite en prison
voilà
qu'en même temps dormez-vous
environ maximum 2 or 2 aura mis par nuit
c'est pas suffisant ça mais je bois
beaucoup
buvez combien
entre 15 et vanille par jour quels sont
vos projets dans la bay arena plus c'est
fini croix vie c'est le principal
n'imaginez plus rien pour vous l'an j'ai
fait ma vie
[Musique]
oh
j'ai aussi le
fond mon pays m'a gâché tout parce que
la mère plaisait jeune alexis la
photo vous la pose à ce jouet mais c'est
essayer de m'en sortir l'enfant j'essaie
de débrouiller comme je peux poser au
retour du travail je leur envoie là
l'air parce qu'elle est toujours en vie
mais je les dunes je n'ai pas perdu et
je boxe à bouaye comme ça pourtant elle
est au courant
mais ça ma boîte et de la famille mais
je veux pas qu'on va kombouaré a comme
ça
[Musique]
j'ai vécu pendant quatre années dans la
dans le métro qu'est-ce qui fait dans la
vie qu'un jour comme ça on se décide
d'aller d'aller vivre là-bas
de petit boulot en petit boulot on
arrive un jour on peut plus payer son
loyer et on se retrouve carrément à la
rue en quinze jours trois semaines de
ton les économistes qui a pu rien c'est
terminé
il faut tu te retrouver quelque chose
quand on n'a pas d'argent c'est le métro
ou les foyers
alors vous vous sentez maintenant qui
physiquement sortie où vous pensez vous
pouvez un jour ou l'autre plongée on
peut retomber dans le temps dans le
métro on peut être à la rue ça vous fait
peur
de replonger vous
les bleus de corps d'appartenance ceux
de la ratp redoutés pour leur brutalité
et eux ceux de la police jugée plus bas
aubin nous aussi que est pas familière
au début il ya que j'étais là dedans
mumbai et ceux qui étaient c'était
pareil c'était un manque de volonté et
c'est parce qu'ils voulaient bien mais
là de nouveau je pense que c'est plus
pareil souvent aussi vous fait une image
de paris on veut tu viens au monte à
paris pour chercher du travail alors que
maintenant il n'y a plus rien ça a été
très dur pour moi de jeu si des fois je
parle avec eux et je sais de les diriger
on dit oui puis des fois ils font rien
quel regard avez-vous sur les clochards
bien bien des gars comme les autres pour
tout le monde
les êtres humains
et bravo
elle va alors entamer dont la bourse
fait bien les choses
alors toi m'a aidé
et il rigole mme à la maison ils font le
ménage les makes
wimbledon tu comprends c'est mon titre
ici verrières debout voilà
[Musique]
le viol y est tu peux m'en prendre sa
retraite piano j'étais en mais plus
encore toi là attends je vous en ai dit
balle la grève est ce que c'est bon et
j'ai vu tu veux libère toi non non un
boulonnais
vous
destination nanterre unique structure en
europe capable de les accueillir de les
soigner et de leur donner une bouffée
d'air
[Musique]
enfin concédé
oui
[Musique]
avec moi allez allez bien allez c'est
parti tu ne pars pas avec les loups
mais tout est ouvert
voilà
vous avez le droit de chanter la
marseillaise pendant ce temps là où vous
voulez pas comme non directement
ces gens
n'ont encore rien que c'est fini ok
ils sont agressés en permanence en fait
ils vivent ils vivent dans cette dans
cet état de stress permanent que ce soit
dans la rue ou dans le métro ils se font
agresser régulièrement par des bande de
loubards skins punk et c'est qui qui
s'amuse à les agresser alors l'agression
se passe généralement de la façon
suivante on commence par balancer au
visage de la victime un jet de gaz
lacrymogène qui est laisse des séquelles
et des blessures gravissime les lésions
de l'oeil parfois irréversibles à tel
point que deux de mes patients ont dû
subir une intervention qui consistait à
leur enlever l'oeil carrément une fois
ce gaz lacrymogènes utilisés le reste
suit tout naturellement et là ils se
font tabasser parfois à mort et nous
arrive ici dans des conditions
traumatologique grave et ces agressions
peuvent donc venir aussi bien
l'extérieur que de l'intérieur de leur
groupe ce qui ne fait qu'augmenter
finalement le risque ils n'ont entre eux
aucune solidarité malgré ce qu'on
pourrait croire et se bat pour tout et
pour rien une façon d'exister
le clochard à quelqu un de seuls
entièrement seul et sa solitude en
seulement lui pèse pas le cacher heureux
mais c'est aussi une ouverture vers la
localisation vers la dépression
c'est aussi une ouverture vers la perte
totale de notions d'avenir ce qui
explique qu'il ne sût qui ne se suicide
pas en fait pour se suicider il faut
avoir une notion de son avenir euh non
l'avenir l'avenir l'avait rarement plus
loin que deux ou trois jours c'est la
raison pour laquelle le suicide est
extrêmement rare chez eux
il ya longtemps que vous vous donnez pas
depuis l'âge de 7 ans j'ai quitté les
filles dont l'âge de 17 ans
qu'est ce qui vous y emmener
ici donc ce qui vous a amené à entrer
dans la zone
c'est dire que j'ai en fait je faisais
stage et qu'une prof et on va faire
voyages à paris et moi par essam a pu et
tout j'ai flashé sur le forum des halles
et tout c'est pour ça que je suis
revenue j'ai tous restés là bas sur
paraître premières auditions
quels sont vos projets dans la vie
projet ce que j'apprécie travail et
pierre-marie se dévore
tout ce que je fais tout ce que je
demande un bonus c'est rien d'autre vous
pensez pouvoir y arriver
avec mes nerfs et je ne sais pas je mets
mes dépression nerveuse je sais pas si
ce que vous avez la volonté au fond de
vous en sortir
oui si je veux aider la volonté gens
mais
alors qu'est ce qui vous empêche alors
actuellement m
j'espère je donne tout
si l'on tient compte d'un degré
d'alcoolisation tout à fait massif dans
la moyenne tourne aux alentours de 5 à 6
litres de vin par jour on imagine très
bien que la santé en sang tout ceci
allié un contexte de vie totalement
défavorisant
manque de sommeil et manque d'hygiène la
peur des agressions le stress permanent
etc etc on aboutit finalement un état de
santé qui est totalement catastrophique
on observe régulièrement des lésions ou
pied
puisque la perte ou le vol plus
particulièrement d'une paire de
chaussures chez mes clients est un
événement tout à fait dramatique surtout
en hiver si bien que le fait de
conserver ses chaussures pendant
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
abouti à des lésions cutanées des pieds
qui sont tout à fait catastrophique et
les pathologies cutanées représente
malgré tout 35 % de nos activités
suivies de près par les problèmes
directement liés à l'alcoolisme le
patient lorsqu'il est ivre et qui
cherche la chaleur s'allonge sur une
sur une bouche de chaleur
les mouvements du physiologique du
sommeil disparaissent à cause et les
bris y était et l'association de la
durée de la compression bv de la chaleur
sèche abouti à des brûlures qui sont
gravissimes
enfin le jeu
eh ouais
à voir
[Musique]
docteur en géographie
que je mange en bourse que la tête si
vous restez
pénalement
dans la plupart d'entre eux ont 6e
totalement perdu notion de ce que ça
peut être que la santé de ce que ça peut
être que le bien-être au niveau de la
santé donc il faut leur faire récupérer
pris avec précaution et doucement cette
image de leur santé de façon à les
amener à se faire soigner il faut le
faire une façon douce que les choses se
fassent doucement très doucement
j'allais dire une sorte de lenteur
inversement proportionnelle à la
rapidité avec laquelle ils sont dégradés
cette dégradation est tout à fait
involontaire comme a été leur passage
dans la rue qui n'a jamais été un choix
faut absolument de sauter de l'idée que
le clochard et dans la rue par choix
c'est faux il est dans la rue par une
succession d'événements qui sont tombées
sur le coin de la figure brutalement
qu'ils ont amené d'une façon inéluctable
à passer à la rue il n'a jamais choisi
son passage à la rue de la même façon
qu'il n'a jamais choisi d'avoir des poux
ni d'avoir des plaisirs monde et dans la
mesure où tout ce processus est
involontaire et inconscient là je pense
que le travail d'un médecin en général
et d'intervenir là dessus tout
simplement aidé de soigner sans sans se
poser la question savoir dans le fond
est ce que j'ai vraiment droit ce que
j'ai pas droit un type qui devant moi
qui est en train de mourir je suis
désolé je me déplacer je le sois
watteau
atta
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
at-on jamais seul
[Musique]
et